thank you no Mel B's turbulent story
well thanks again because the Spice Girl
has saved some of her most startling
revelations for et and these are
unbelievable Michelle Turner scored the
first American interview with Mel B
about her tell-all book and it is
shocking Michelle is standing by in
London I gotta ask were you surprised by
what you heard I was surprised by a lot
of the things that Mel revealed to me I
didn't know how extreme the drug abuse
had gotten now she says she used it as a
way to cope with an abusive husband you
said you were doing up to six lines of
coke a day when you were at X Factor's
well one of the things I said there's
many other thing and it's a symptom of
what I was dealing with how things
affect you how you cope Mel B says she
hit an emotional rock bottom during her
tumultuous 10-year marriage to Stefan
Belafonte she claims he abused her but
she lied about it to protect their image
he calls herself a pathetic liar yeah
because I was but I was also really good
at because that's what you you have to
do because you don't want anybody
intruding in your perfect marriage you
don't want anybody uncovering or
unveiling what is what's happening or
what has happened he has denied her
claims and they divorced earlier this
year meanwhile you might be surprised -
Mel calls the love of her life
can we talk about Eddie yeah in her new
memoir brutally honest Mel says she and
Eddie Murphy dated for nine months in
2006 and planned to get married they
have an 11 year old daughter you still
love him yeah I always will are you
still in love it no he has a lady and
he's got a little baby and angels at
your house right now you know I think
that's very unfair for me to talk like
that because he's in a committed
relationship is going on his second baby
with this lovely lady and my daughter's
there right now she'd have spent
Thanksgiving with him next up for Mel
the Spice Girls 2019 tour you know
there's a lot of celebrities that are
going nutso about you guys getting back
together and since Victoria is out maybe
there could be like a celebrity fan
steppin Adele is red tea for y'all to
get back on stage and must-own Chrissy
Teigen all they're like losing their
minds can that happen and I will just go
say yes of course they're gonna happen
the girls first I think that's a great
idea and in fact we're having a creative
meeting next week we want our fans to
know that this is gonna be like a
celebration and we're gonna go back in
town and that is what we want what we
really really want melody told me that
she's very relieved that the tour is
selling so well but of course it's
selling well you're the Spice Girls and
her book is about to do the same thing
it is skyrocketing up the charts already
and she told me that she not only wrote
this book for her but for all women
dance back to you know hopefully it'll
help some others too she'll thank you
very much
[Music]